bfm business stéphane soumier réveille
la planète et qu'au bout non les
business jean marc jancovici donc est
avec le bonjour jean marc jancovici
merci beaucoup de venir nous voir
spécialistes du climat ingénieurs on
parlera dans la deuxième partie de cette
interview de ce que vous faites avec
votre cabinet conseil s'appelle carbone
4 et de la façon finalement dont les
entreprises prennent ce sujet au sérieux
peut être davantage que les citoyens ce
que moi je voulais d'abord parler avec
vous d'un élément vous mettez sur la
table et qui est dire en fait on ne fait
pas assez peur aux gens je vous ai vu
dire un de mes confrères
on n'a jamais vu quelqu'un descendre de
son 4 4 parce qu'un ours polaire étaient
à la dérive sur un glaçon je suis dit
qu'il a raison jean marc jancovici je
n'ai pas peur mais non je n'ai pas peur
en fait c'est exactement le thème d'un d
un des chapitres d'un livre que j'ai à
sortir absolument qui est de dire que
dans mais c'est à leur corps défendant
parce qu'ils l'ont pas fait exprès mais
dans la manière dont le dossier a été
vulgarisée par le monde médiatique sur
la base du dossier scientifique
on s'est focalisé sur un objectif qui
est loin de 1000 sans vous on n'arrête
pas de parler en matière de changements
climatiques de ce qui se passera en 2100
2100 tout montre mort donc les tous les
gens qui nous écoutent sont morts sans
exception en 2100 et la deuxième chose
qu'on fait c'est que l'on se focalise
sur un indicateur sur lesquels les gens
se méprennent qui est une température
sur une température ça fait peur à
personne
quelques degrés de variation ça fait
peur à personne et quand on doit
illustrer puisque les médias modernes
ont besoin d'avoir des images pour
illustrer en général les dégâts du
changement climatique en france il ya
vous avez deux choses auxquelles vous
n'échappez pas c'est soit la banquise
qui fond et l'ours blanc qui se
lamentent dessus soit un ouragan avec
des gens très malheureux mais en france
nous n'avons pas d'ouragan enfin on a
des tempêtes de temps en temps mais on
n'a pas de l'ouragan et n'ya pas d'ours
blancs et pas de banquise accord donc
les gens ne voient pas que le problème
puisse être ennuyeux et on peut pas
vraiment leur en vouloir mais vous vous
décidez derrière des catastrophes qui
alors j'ai l'impression sont bons
beaucoup trop loin peut-être que l'ours
polaire c'est un pas assez loin dans les
dégâts pourraient apporter de
réchauffement climatique mais quand vous
le dit que la guerre en syrie est
provoquée par le réchauffement
climatique vous même jean marc jancovici
alors pour le coup vous allez beaucoup
trop loin je n'avais pas beaucoup trop
loin je dis qu'il ya un déterminant
énergie et climat non ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment alors le
déterminant énergie il commence au début
du 20e siècle
il vous aura pas échappé que les états
du moyen-orient ont toutes des
frontières toutes droites et ils ont des
frontières tout droite parce qu'à
l'époque on s'est partagé les champs de
pétrole et on n'a pas dit tiens on va
mettre tous les chiffres d'un côté tous
les sunnites de l'autre sont les
frontières de la colonisation jean marc
jancovici en afrique aussi sans pétrole
ils ont des frontières tout droitier des
frontières tout droite entre et partager
les ressources au loin chaque fois donc
donc oui d'orient on s'est partagé le
pétrole donc c'est explicite l'irak est
une création anglaise la syrie et pour
partie une création française
donc vous avez un premier déterminant
pétrole qui datent de cette époque là
oui mais qu'on paye pour partie
aujourd'hui vous avez un deuxième
déterminant énergétique qui a causé une
partie afrique et l origine des
printemps arabes
c'est l'absence de touristes à partir de
dans les pays qui en dépendent à la fois
la cie rien mais la tunisie et l'egypte
ont besoin des touristes pour payer
leurs importations alimentaires et en
les touristes sont pas là parce qu'il ya
une crise et cette crise elle est due au
pétrole
c'est un choc pétrolier qui a provoqué
la crise donc on a un deuxième
déterminant énergie dans cette histoire
le troisième déterminant climatique
vous allez me parler et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs historiquement d'une dune de
très mauvaises récoltes en russie qui
ont amené un stress sur les matières
premières alimentaires de lésions aux
années effectivement le début de la
révolution arabe en tunisie et en egypte
et on égypte l'égypte est le plus gros
importateur de blé au monde
moi je vais vous dire c'est pas une
question climatique c'est une question
qu'on a sous investis sur le domaine des
matières premières alimentaires et c'est
parce que on a refusé la
financiarisation des matières premières
animales
on voulait aller chercher en scène un
déterminant conjoncturel c'est à dire le
monde étant ce qu'il est ce qui a causé
le choc
cette année là et pas une autre année
c'est deux choses c'est d'abord
l'assèchement progressif du bassin
méditerranéen qui est une cause attendu
est en cours du réchauffement climatique
et ça ça mais reste c'est un facteur de
pression sur la production alimentaire
méditerranéenne
après vous avez aussi une croissance
démographique qui n'a rien à voir avec
le changement climatique mais aussi un
facteur de pression donc je dis pas que
c'est la seule cause mais je dis que
dans ce qui s'est passé vous avez des
déterminants qui viennent
de l'aspect énergie et climat mais
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment nous faire
peur jean marc jancovici
c'est la bonne est ce que c'est la bonne
solution parce qu'il ya des gens qui
arrêtent de fumer si on ne leur dit pas
à un moment ou un autre peut-être que
c'est une bonne idée de le faire il faut
pas que ça ça veut dire que vous avez le
sentiment que ça ne passera que par la
contrainte
c'est à dire que ce dont on va parler
tout à l'heure sur l'ensemble des
solutions sont en train de créer
auxquels sont en train de réfléchir les
entreprises ne suffira pas ça veut dire
que si on ne met pas il ya deux manières
de faire avancer un être humain il ya
l'envi et la peur la peur seul est
toujours mauvaise conseillère
mais là en l'occurrence on est face à un
problème qui est trop important pour que
l' envie seul soit suffisante tant qu'à
un moment il faut quand même se dire oui
il faut le faire et le oui il faut le
faire traditionnellement ça s'appelle
une contrainte
on a collectivement accepté l'idée qu'il
fallait payer des impôts alors certains
trouvent qu'on en paye trop d'autres
qu'on en paye par ac mais peu importe on
est quand même fin personne ne prône le
fait qu'on supprime la totalité des
impôts et bien à partir du moment où on
accepte ça derrière il ya une contrainte
quatre ans qui s'appelle le fisc qui
vous courent derrière si vous les payez
pas et c'est donc oui quand on se dit il
faut faire les choses
ça devient légitime de temps en temps
quand on est une contrainte et qu'on la
respecte c'est la peur que cette peur
suscite un sentiment de rejet
c'est toujours leur il ya une partie de
la population et qui rejette totalement
l'ensemble de ces questions justement
parce que la jeune actrice qu'on nous
fasse peur comme il ya une partie des
gens qui viennent dans ce studio qui
disent y'a trop d'impôts il faudra donc
c'est une religion qui viennent dans ce
studio donc donc à un moment c'est
évident que la contrainte suscite
toujours une forme de rejet il faut le
l'enjeu de cette affaire c'est justement
d'essayer de faire partager la
connaissance qui est objectivement pas
très rassurantes sur le dossier du
changement climatique pour que l'on
suscite une adhésion au fait qu'il va en
falloir se relever et se remuer ses des
défis à relever un défi c'est à la fois
des efforts et des satisfactions mais
vous avez toujours les deux on parle de
la façon dont justement les entreprises
prennent la mesure de ce défi alors pour
le coup et à travers ce que vous faites
vous même et votre cabinet de conseil
qui s'appelle carbone 4 tout cela dans
un instant 8h16 c'est bfm business
bfm business stéphane soumier réveille
la planète échos
boullemant libye on continue à discuter
avec jean marc jancovici avant de parler
de ce que vous faites au coeur de
carbone karaté de la façon dont les
entreprises prennent conscience pour de
bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons mais en
tout cas sont en train d'agir juste un
mot il ya un affrontement nord-sud dans
cette histoire il ya un sud l'inde par
exemple dont on parle assez peu et très
très clair le gouvernement maudit est
très très claire aucune contrainte nous
avons besoin du charbon et des bonnes
vieilles centrales à fuel pour nous
développer
fermez le ban ce que dit le gouvernement
nous dit est probablement le reflet de
sa contraintes internes
l'inde c'est une mosaïque c'est une
immense démocratie c'est assez souvent
le bazar soit dit en passant c'est vrai
c'est une c'est une constellation
d'ethnies différentes religions
différentes de et c'est donc en fait
nous dit à mon avis il ne dit qu'une
seule chose il dit mais quand bien même
je m'engagerai à quelque chose j'ai pas
les moyens de le faire respecter en
interne oui mais tout de même cette idée
dire prix du carbone élevé par exemple
et cette idée de dire bon bah c'est pas
très grave les africains paieront un peu
plus cher leur développement
les indiens paieront un peu plus faire
le cher leur développement les chinois
paieront un peu plus cher leur
développement
on comprend qu'ils aient du mal à
l'accepter au nom de quoi je pense que
la chine et l'inde c'est de ces deux cas
de figure qui sont extrêmement
différents la chine est n'est pas une
démo colle pas une démocratie
la chine est un pays qui résonne long
terme assez facilement ceci allant avec
cela et la chine a par exemple déjà mis
sur la table des visions de l'avenir ou
d'ici quelques dizaines d'années et
revient en quelques dizaines d'années
son approvisionnement électrique serait
basé pour partie sur le nucléaire est
pour partie sur les renouvelables dont
ils ont déjà dit des choses qui vont
dans le sens de ce qu'on a envie nous
d'entendre et la chine soit dit en
passant est capable de faire des choses
inimaginables en france quand le
gouvernement chinois dit je vais fermer
les six pour cent des usines les plus
polluantes
c'est comme si chez nous les dréal
débarqué en disant je vais fermer six
usines sur 100 ou plus imaginez le
tableau donc la chine est capable de
faire des choses je suis sûr que ce
régime politique justement qui lui donne
cette capacité de faire les choses soit
un régime enviable jean marc jancovici
quand même c'est à dire il faut avec eux
l'attendait attendait la question
fondamentale parce que je voulais venir
les formats c'est la démocratie pour
sauver la planète
la question fondamentale moi je la pose
dans l'autre sens c'est est ce que notre
insouciance sur vous savez la planète
c'est le seul vaisseau spatial habitable
que nous connaissions
si on le fichant lèvres si on le fiche
en l'air notre pib va pas aimer d'accord
donc il faut pas croire que l'on peut
avoir d'un côté une économie qui se
porte bien et de l'autre côté une
planète qui se porte mal à un moment ou
à un autre si la planète entre
guillemets va pas bien c'est à dire si
les ressources sur lesquelles on base
notre système productif sont pas là il
n'y a pas de système productif derrière
donc quand on s'occupe de
l'environnement il faut pas voir ça
comme s'est séparé des hommes et on fait
ça parce que c'est un supplément d'âme
etc
il faut le voir comme quelque chose de
très égoïste au sens collectif
pas au sens individuel de très égoïste
qui est si on fiche en l'air de vaisseau
spatial on va vraiment pas aimé donc le
le l'idée qu' il ne faudrait il faudrait
refuser les contraintes parce qu'on peut
vivre dans un monde sans contrainte et
continuer à jouir de tous sans que à
aucun moment on en paye la facture
malheureusement ce n'est pas une vision
économique correct ici et justement
c'est ce dont on attaque mais si parce
que les entreprises sont en train de
trouver des solutions alors que les
pertes énergétiques est en train de vous
donner une puissance que personne
n'imaginait il ya encore dix ans j'en
argent c'est vrai et c'est faux je vais
commencer par les mauvaises nouvelles
allez-y si vous regardez comment a
évolué et l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie mondiale sur les 15 dernières
années ça n'a pas bougé 0 c'est la même
que il ya 15 ans donc ça veut dire que
si vous prenez le problème de manière
globale les choses s'améliorent pas
maintenant si vous prenez certains
sous-ensembles avec certains acteurs
particuliers certaines applications
particulières là vous allez trouver des
progrès mais si globalement ça bouge pas
ça veut dire que ailleurs il ya des
secteurs où au contraire ça se dégrade
il est temps un diffuseur mais il faut
que ça se diffuse en face de l'école
aidera est-ce que l'espagne par exemple
pour attendre que ça se diffuse parce
que l'espagne a une efficacité
énergétique de son économie aujourd'hui
qui est la même qu'il ya 50 ans la
turquie a dégradé la sienne le brésil a
dégradé la sienne le vietnam a dégradé
la sienne les philippines ont dégradé la
leur et c'est donc vous avez plein de
pays
donc vous dites bullshit efficacité
énergétique dit la bullshit jeudi le
temps sera son oeuvre le progrès diffuse
nécessairement dans un sens je vous dis
non c'est pas ce que disent les chiffres
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on puisse rien
faire
ça veut juste dire je reste assis dans
mon canapé et les ingénieurs vont bosser
pour moi dans la bonne direction je dis
ça ça marche pas un peu le sentiment que
j'ai
malheureusement c'est pas ce que disent
les chiffres c'est aussi un peu le
sentiment que j'avais avant de regarder
les chiffres
malheureusement c'est pas ce que disent
les chiffres n'ont donc si vous faites
un peu de fact checking comme vérité et
ben ça marche pas par contre on peut la
voir si on le veut et si on le veut vous
vous rendez compte que vous avez
toujours deux choses que vous devez
mettre dans le même panier
vous devez mettre de la technique ça oui
vous devez être de la créativité
l'innovation mais vous devez mettre de
l'économie et donc on retourne sur la
contrainte que vous n'aimez pas
seulement non mais ça ne marchera pas si
ça marche on a dit les gens on doit
boucler leur ceinture de sécurité au
début
d'ailleurs ça marchera pas si les gens
le font on a dit vous devez amener votre
voiture au contrôle technique on y verra
la marche là-bas les gens le font et on
dit vous n'avez pas le droit de tuer
votre voisin s'il fait trop de bruit
l'élu fait bon donc à un moment la
contrainte
elle est là on l'accès est bon et on a
même fait pire que ça on a dit à mon
chum et c'est pas bon pour la santé donc
on accepte l'idée que c'est interdit de
fumer dans les yeux bleus dans les lieux
publics est globalement les gens
respectent
bon donc la contrainte est si elle est
comprise c'est ça le w ça c'est le pc la
pédagogie de la contrainte qui est
important et on en revient au début
l'idée du mans donc si on la comprend on
l'accepté à ce moment où transforma
contrainte en défi c'est parce que la
montagne est haute que c'est un défi de
monter dessus et quand vous y arrivez
vous êtes particulièrement content et
que même vous vous dites que les gens
qui sont montés dessus sur les gens
super et c'est ça il faut voir le
problème de la décarbonation de
l'économie comme grosse montagne sur
laquelle il faut monter et donc il ya
des contraintes absolument mais il ya
aussi des satisfactions de trois
histoires de fin de ce que vous faites
au quotidien avec votre cabinet de
conseil s'appelle carbone 4 et qui
accompagne justement les entreprises qui
veulent essayer de bouger de trois
exemples il nous reste 2 minutes 30 à
peu près là on essaye on s'occupe
beaucoup de tout ce qui est amélioration
de la performance du bâtiment
donc on essaye d'aider des acteurs de ce
secteur là à soit mieux se faire
entendre soit voir comment ils
pourraient se positionner pour que on
accélère le rythme de la rénovation des
bâtiments déjà construits
vous avez cassé les bâtiments pour les
reconstruire en france rythme actuel 6 1
pour mille serre chaque année il ya un
pour mille du parc
si vous voulez décarbonés les bâtiments
en 30 ans ça le fait pas absolument
donc on essaye d'aider des acteurs qui
sont dans ce domaine là à faire affaire
à faire mieux et plus vite on va dire à
se faire mieux entendre voilà un exemple
on essaye d'aider des acteurs dans le
domaine de la mobilité qui là aussi est
said décarbonés les transports
alors il ya des choses parfois
totalement contre intuitive et une des
choses totalement contre intuitif qui a
peut-être vous abusez c'est que quand
vous regardez les choses d'un peu près
et que vous regardez comment on peut
décarbonés des transports le plus vite
possible avec les investissements les
plus léger possible ceci les
investissements sont trop lourds vous
allez pas vite et bien vous rendez
compte de manière très étonnante que la
route est la solution à la route et le
pétrole est la solution au pétrole
c'est à dire que la première marche de
manoeuvre est celle qui râle plus vite
c'est de faire des voitures plus petites
et qui consomment moins et de remplacer
les voitures non pas par des erreurs
parce que ça et on n'aura pas les
capitaux pour le faire très vite mais
par des autocars pas des autocars longue
distance 1 des autocars périurbain et
vous dit très justement la voiture
électrique qui apparaît c'est vrai comme
une espèce d'icône là pour lutter contre
le réchauffement n'ont laissé tomber la
rupture electric entend qu'elle
s'installe on sera tous morts en
revanche le mode en éclats de litre le
moteur à explosion à 2 litres ça c'est
la vraie solution ça on peut le faire
demain matin on peut le faire demain
enfin demain matin il faut quelques
années mais on peut le faire en bois et
sillonner c'est quasiment fait
effectivement pour les petites voitures
pour les petits la seule chose qu'on ne
sait pas faire en quelques années dans
le cadre réglementaire européen actuel
c'est de privilégier les acteurs qui
s'affairent dans le déploiement de ce
genre de choses
pourquoi elles le font ces entreprises
je marche aucune apparition mais passons
pas plus ils ont pas plus peur que moi
les patrons de ces entreprises j'en suis
convaincu donc pourquoi est-ce qu'ils le
font alors hein
il faut leur demander pour savoir si dix
ans plus tard que vous et vous leur de
l'enlever vous donnerai des noms et 2
ils le font parce que toute entreprise
vieille comme le monde a une obligation
de favoriser ces affaires la mienne
comme les autres et donc ils le font
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est leur
intérêt et qu'à une prise de conscience
que très très vite
le business model pourrait se dégrader
si jamais on évolue et pas sur ces
questions on aime à croire même si c'est
pas toujours vrai mais de temps en temps
c'est vrai que ils sont convaincus du
fait que d'aller dans ce sens là est
meilleur pour les affaires que de ne pas
te donne pas y aller alors après sept
jours du différentiel 1 c'est pas
nécessairement le monde merveilleux d'un
côté et l'enfer de l'autre mais il pense
que de commencer à s'orienter dans cette
direction vous
art de s'orienter franchement dans cette
direction c'est l'intérêt de leurs
salariés et donc de leur entreprise
merci jean marc jancovici lire merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous voir ce matin
sur bfm business